well I absolutely absolutely believe
that frickin border has its place in the
universe and is going to be around you
know forever you know
the Internet is certainly an option and
it certainly can be a very good option
for people in buying the categories we
sell in terms of books music DVDs etc I
believe in the Internet I believe it
online retailing that's the reason that
we just took back our e-commerce
business from Amazon after seven years
and just relaunched our our website
borders calm recently and we think we
have great opportunity in that area
however we know that customers like the
bookstore experience there is a you know
they've had the option of shopping
online already and we have really you
know heavy readers or a lot of our major
customers they certainly understand the
options out there yet they will come in
our stores and spend almost an hour in
our stores and that's because they like
the experience that they have in our
bookstore I was one of those people
myself as a customer before I ever took
the job before I decided to come here
you know would go to the cafe and you
get some you get a cup of coffee and and
you you browse a little bit you might
have a specific book you're looking for
or not you might just be browsing and
find things that you can you know look
at magazines listen some music and and
you buy a few things along the way one
of the key things that we're trying to
do is take advantage of that where you
have the customer who's just browsing
through the store by selling them more
and I think a lot of it can be
accomplished through improvement in our
merchandise presentation our emphasis on
key items impulse items this type of
thing absolutely